ان المنصب الذي كان محطه اهتمام اكثر من
غيره كان منصبه وزيره الدفاع الذي شغلته
لمده خمسه اعوام وهي الوزاره الاكثر
تكاملا حيث نهتم فيها بالمسائل الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه ولكن ايضا بالشؤون التي لها
صله بالبحث العلمي وصناعه الاسلحه
والمشاكل الاقتصاديه والمسائل المتعلقه
بالمعدات ولا سيما منها في بلد يمتلك سلاح
النويا وهذا امر مهم في هذه الفتره كانت
هناك الكثير من العمليات في افغانستان
التي زرتها مرارا وفي الكونغو في افريقيا
في لبنان وتشاده اذا في كل الاماكن في
الخارج ومنها كسوف في اوروبا كنت على
تواصل مع تلك البلدان ومع العسكريين هذه
الخبره كانت غنيه من خلال قياده رجال
ونساء يقبلون ان يضحوا من اجل بلادهم اذا
كنت على تناغم مع هؤلاء الرجال والنساء
وانا ساعترف انني كاول امراه تسلمت وزاره
دفاع كان هذا ايضا عنصرا مهما سمح لي ان
اكتشف الكثير من الامور لدى الرجال
والنساء وثقافات البلدان اخرى كنت على
سبيل المثال اعرف بلدان الخليج ولكن ليس
كثيرا وقد تفنني في تلك الفتره زياره
المنطقه مرات عده تعرفت خلالها على شخصيات
المنطقه لفهم الناس وهذه كانت الخبره
الاكثر ثراءا بالنسبه لي هناك وزارات اخرى
كانت مهمه ايضا مثل وزاره الداخليه كنت
فيها على تواصل مباشره مع الحياه اليوميه
الفرنسيه
من اجل تحسين اداء الوزاره وتحفيز
العاملين فيها ولكن لم انكر في الوزاره
الداخليه الا ونصف وهذه المده لم تسمح
للقيام بكل الاصلاحات المطلوبه وقتها
بعكسي وزاره الدفاع التي مكثت فيها لاكثر
من خمسه اعوام وهو ما سمح لي القيامه بعدد
اكبر من الاصلاحات